hello there my name is judy tiberu i'm a
phd candidate at the abortion lab at the
university of minnesota before i start i
want to say thank you for the organizers
of this napb conference especially sarah
davison for allowing me to talk to you a
little bit about my interest in using
advanced some biotechnology tools for
improving orphan crops and what i'm
calling green revolution through gene
resolution and ortho and crops
so just to give you a little personal
background and my connection to this
topic i grew up in ethiopia which is a
country in custody or in africa and a
country that's technically reliant on
agriculture for both domestic youth and
exports however
ethiopia suffers from drastic food
shortage and malnutrition and there are
multiple factors for this but i want to
focus more on
what i believe is a major solution for
agricultural productivity not only in
the country but also in south air and
africa where
climate change is expected to exacerbate
the situation the current situation and
where um it's expected that
population will double by 2050
and so um i think it's a smart way to
improve the crops that are cultivated in
these countries
by using advanced biotechnology tools
coupled with traditional breeding
so the green revolution you all know
abroad about uh drastic
food and food security improvement
agricultural productivity in the uh
regions that it was implemented and
where it was successful and however
africa did not
benefit from this the green revolution
was not successful
uh for the most part and this was
because of the fact that africa has very
diverse um climates and crops that are
cultivated throughout the continent
which makes it very difficult for
traditional breeding and most of these
countries did not have the investment
power to build
the pipeline for
improving these crops through
breeding
some of these crops that are cultivated
throughout sub-saharan africa are shown
here sorghum actually isn't an orphan
crop anymore because of the recent
improvement work that's been conducted
on it increasing the yields and the
adaptation to various abiotic stresses
that i used to face
um
however most of these
crops have while adaptation to the
regions that they're grown in which
tends to be harsh climates with
water scarcity and also various abiotic
and biotic factors
um
also
they uh some of these crops tend to have
pretty good nutritional benefits um in
terms of having some
nutrients that aren't found in
major crops for example tess
is a cereal crop that's cultivated in
ethiopia and i'll talk about it later on
but it is a cereal grain
with high calcium and iron and it's also
gluten free so it's actually gaining
popularity now in the western the
functional or gluten free food market
because that's this characteristic
um however though even though these
crops have all these benefits both in an
ergonomic and nutritional sense
they tend to be very low protein
productivity and labor intensive um for
cultivation and also post-harvest
processing
and this is based on
mainly because of the fact that they
haven't had much improvement other than
the selection process that farmers do
when planting these crops
and so um
hopefully with the advent of gene
editing tools we can apply
these techniques to improve these crops
and when we talk about gene editing
tools i want to make sure that everyone
is on the same page so generally allows
for a precise targeted modification of
genomes
we're talking about plant genomes here
however it does require um genomic
resource data or reference genome and
the knowledge of of
genes and their functions which um
traditional greeting doesn't really
require right
but it is more more rapid and more
precise if you have those um
those data on this those resources
there are various tools available
currently for
specific applications such as insertions
and deletions using talents or crisper
cast mines and then base editors are
the most recently reported
which allow for specific modifications
of base pairs or amino acids for a more
precise and
alteration of the gene expression rather
than
deletion or insertion
so there have been various applications
of these gene editing tools and various
for our major crops shown here and the
application range from
benefits such as uh resistant to abiotic
stress factors biotic stress factors
overall
yield um as well as consumer benefits so
i was involved in a project
that improved potato storability
by just targeting one gene using
talons and so we were able to
knock out
this gene that controls for um that
controls the reduction of sugars
which um when they are stored and
processed at high temperature for
example when making um
fries or chips
these reduced sugar tend to
turn into these bitter brown spots
that um have been reported to have
acrylamides which is a possible
carcinogen so by just knocking out this
one gene we're able to produce potato
lines that are healthier to consumers
so moving these gene editing approaches
to organ crops require various
advancements in technology such as
sequencing phenotyping and
bioinformatics and there has been rapid
improvements in these
technologies
reference genomes for orphan crops and
four different varieties have been
are
reported and are being
put into data public accessible
databases which will help researchers
globally to be able to access these and
perform their own gene editing
applications in
the class that they're interested in and
also these advancements are helping
improve
the gene identification and functional
characterization work and so it takes
less time than it used to take with some
of um with the utilization of these
tools
another advancement that's key is
advancements in plant transformation
methods you might have heard that
plant transformation tends to be the
bottleneck for
uh gene editing tissue culture
specifically
delivery of the
editing reagents and then into the plant
tissue and then going through tissue
culture to try to get a region to try to
regenerate a transformed
plants usually takes a lot of time
expertise and resources
that most
labs in
especially developing countries don't
have the capacity for so genotype
independent transformation methods using
developmental regulators
which has been really
at the forefront of this
field
is
helping move forward
diminish this bottleneck and corsava
agrosciences has done a lot of work in
this um
in this
forefront and also
sharing their techniques and
technologies with institutions and
researchers
globally another one is the tissue calls
for free transformation methods
our lab at the damn voices lab reported
two papers last year where one used
virus
to
transform or edit uh
plants
and then another one use agrobacterium
to also edit
various different species
and this both of these methods gives the
chance the tissue culture um
process
which not only saved a lot of time but
resources as well and so some of these
advancements are key of course
communication and collaborative
platforms are also um have grown through
this covet
time
zoom and other platforms allow for
data sharing and
working together uh for training
purposes
so this allows for
the um sharing of
these tools and technique with
researchers that
may not have had access to it in
previous years
there are various um traits
improvements that can be carried out in
orphaned crops as you can see here some
of these orphan crops
suffer from
these um
biotic and abiotic factors and there are
various genes that have already been
characterized to improve some of the
tree simple plant architecture for
example
most of the cereal orchard crops tend to
suffer from plant lodging which was a
huge issue for before the green
revolution and both
wheat and
rice and these genes sd1 and rhq1 were
introduced through the
traditional breeding that took place
during the
green revolution and these could easily
be introduced in
uh orphan cross or from cereal crops
through gene editing as well as some of
these
other
traits and genes associated with them
and so these are
very low-hanging fruits that can easily
be introduced in
various orphan crops
in order to reach their yield potential
and improve their
nutrition as well
one
case study i want to talk about is
cassava cassava is the most important
food crop
globally and also it feeds one third of
africa's population
um it is well adapted to that
environment
but unfortunately it does
require it's a labor-intensive
cultivation process and post-harvest
processing
and
the first reference genome was uh
reported in 2009 and since then
2017 the first demonstration of crispr
castline was reported and since then
there have been a lot of
ongoing work
in improving
cassava through
gene editing approaches
one
from our lab in collaboration with the
danforth institute was
developing herbicides following cassava
targeting the esps the epsps gene using
crispr cas9 and
this glyphosate tolerant cassava is now
being
tested filled
field testing
in the country um in something in africa
that's culturally cassava
another example that dear to my heart is
tough which is a cereal crop that is the
staple um
crop in ethiopia i grew up eating it it
covers about 30 percent of
the cereal the
land that is allocated to cereal
production in the country um however
when
you look at the yield it's the lowest
the lowest yielding of all the cereals
that are also cultivated in the country
and this has to do with the various
limitations listed here susceptibility
to wheat
plant lodging and seed quality
the improvement of
tests is now just starting and this was
because of the fact that we didn't
really have um
a full complete genome of tests until
recently last year a complete genome was
reported and made available and since
then there's an ongoing work to try to
introduce some of the genes that i
talked about previously to
reduce some of these limitations and
reach the yolk potential
of self
so with that i would like to conclude
stating that
technology and advancements and
increased access to these
technologies are key to
using
advanced plant biotechnology tools for
orphan crops and so i talked about
availability of genome being
key and also capacity building in
developing countries is another key
factor in moving
this technology forward so instead of
conducting the research of improving
these crops
in western countries
it's best if we can build a capacity
train scientists researchers in
developing countries so that they are
able to carry out these uh improvement
work on their own staple crops and
hopefully acceptance of these um
edited products
and better policy landscapes and these
regions can really
bring about
these
advancements to farmers and consumers
finally
i am hopeful that we will be able to
adapt to climate change using these
advanced
tools
by de novo domestication of wild type
crops which has already been reported
and also improving these various
orphan crops and different varieties to
be able to develop climate resilient
agricultural
landscapes
and
that is also high yielding and that
meets the nutritional needs of the
growing population
so with that i would like to thank you
for your intent attention and i would
i look forward to our discussions later
on